yes I love a strong man a man that can
like put people in their place in case
anybody well I actually do like Amanda
kind of puts me in my place a guy that
like lets women run all over him like I
don't like that I feel like Andrew's
kind of like that yeah so so maybe we
like Andrew maybe we like him maybe we
do like Andrew hey guys and welcome back
to the Leia Heil pen show I'm here at
the University of Miami and I'm asking
people today whether they're happy that
Andrew take has been released from jail
and is now in house arrest or whether
they think he should be back in jail
guys don't forget to hit the like button
and subscribe with the notifications
Bell on because this is going to get
juicy and we're going to be bringing you
a lot more of it I don't think he should
have been out of jail why do you think
he should be loud jail because what he
did was horrible and I don't know I just
I don't like him why don't you like him
what did he do
uh
uh you don't know what he did
I do but like I don't really know
specifics oh you crazy how can you say
you don't like someone if you don't know
what they did my friend said what did
your friend say
uh
um
I kind of forget it was first semester
wait don't you think like before you
should before someone says oh that
person should be in jail you should like
know what they've done no yes okay so
I'll ask you the question again should
Andrew take me in or out of jail I'm
gonna say um but why you don't know what
he's done how can you say in I just know
he's bad that's all I know he should be
in jail even though they can't find
evidence yeah what oh man that sounds
pretty unethical to anything
it sounds unethical
what the [__] do you think he should be
back in jail or do you think he should
be free I guess free
I've seen like on Instagram like videos
he posts like I guess men find it
inspirational some of it is kind of
douchebag common do you like him
um
uh what is it that makes you go uh like
some things I guess I could kind of
agree with and then others I just think
is like a super like
manly misogynistic opinion do you think
he should be free or do you think he
should be back in jail
to be honest I have no idea why he got
arrested I'm guessing because of the
things that he says I think everyone
takes a two like it's a joke clearly I
don't think he actually thinks that way
so no I don't think he should be in jail
for it
I feel like he should be back in jail
personally
um just because of his behavior on
social media what Behavior specifically
on social media do you feel like he
should be in jail for I feel like he's
just uh very uh he goes at people I mean
I feel like it's very immature way do
you think just because you don't like
some what someone says on social media
should be a reason for them to be in
jail though because it's not a crime it
isn't a crime that's correct gotcha
[__] I think you should be in jail okay
why should he be in jail I just heard
about the whole trafficking Scandal I
don't really know that much about it but
um yeah stop the cap so they were
investigating him for a whole year but
there was never any trial and they
couldn't find any evidence so that's why
they let him go what do you think about
that do you think he should be in jail
or do you think he should be free then
um I think there should have been a
trial but if there was no trial then he
should be free gotcha [__] so should he
be in or out of jail I know I saw the
one video of the girls that were
supposedly being sex trafficked and they
were like getting pizza or something and
um and they just like open the gates and
got pizza I personally think he should
be back until not a huge fan of Andrew
state
empowerment
so what's he done that makes you think
he needs to be in jail
um I don't know all of the things that
happened I just heard pretty bad things
about like things that he says and just
stuff like that and I just don't think
that he should be out there like that I
don't know what
can you give me an example doesn't he
like say things about like woman like
not needing to work and stuff like that
bro what are you talking about man he's
better off not being in jail why because
there isn't any facts to keep him in
there that's interesting because
everyone that I've spoken to today says
that they think Andrew Tate should be in
jail and they have no reason why so do
you like him or not no I like Andrew
take
what do you like about Andrew I think
that he has a lot of interesting points
I believe that this world has gone so
far off on one side and I believe that
he brings balance and I believe that he
has a lot of interesting things and we
should hear him out
opinion well the other day I saw a video
and he was like you know men when they
cheat they're not like they love
somebody and like they come back to that
person that they love but if they cheat
and then they come back to that person
like they're only cheating because let's
consider that an exercise like it's just
an exercise you're just going to the gym
for a couple minutes and then you're
gonna and I was just kind of like damn
like what a way to put like cheating on
your wife is that misogynistical like
because misogynistic means like you hate
women like an inherent hate for women oh
I mean maybe that's not the right word
then gotcha [__] you like Andrew Tate I
don't like Andrew Tate but it's like he
has videos where he's reacting to things
that he said in the past and he like
laughs at it so you can tell it's like
that's not actually like his personality
so you said there were some things that
he says that you don't like let's get
into that so tell me what don't you like
that he said and we'll see if we can
come to an agreement This Is The Stuff
where he's like oh like I should come
home and my wife's there with dinner on
the table and like I get to do whatever
I want to her and she better serve me
like I'm her King and she does nothing
all day except for cook me food and like
be quiet
cook
so if you're with a very successful man
and he's out there working all day it's
quite nice if he's retired you and
you're not working and you have dinner
ready for him on the table no but I
agree cooking for your husband that
works hard for you is awesome I agree
with that but so you do agree with
Andrew but I do agree that cooking for
your husband and like being a sweet wife
is a great thing to do gotcha [__] I
feel like that's his main message
because I when I spoke with him I don't
think he's saying women shouldn't work I
think it's like they don't have to work
and I think she'd be happier serving her
husband rather than serving a boss a CEO
do you want a man that can't you say no
stop the cap what kind of mind you want
um respectful
honest a gentleman what about strong you
want a strong man you're a strong man
yes I love a strong man like a man that
can like put people in their place in
case anybody well I actually do like
Amanda kind of puts me in my place a guy
that like lets women run all over him
like I don't like that I feel like
Andrew's kind of like that yeah so
what did he say on social media that you
think means he should be in jail
um I feel like for the way he goes at
women how they should be in society but
is that a reason to be in jail just
because you don't like what he says
about women like is that a crime no so
he shouldn't be in jail
uh you did say he should be in jail
because you didn't like what he said on
Twitter about women
I totally agree with you I think the
world has gone so crazy we've gone like
way too far to the left and he does
bring back that balance so why do you
think people hate him so much because
people are sheep do you like him no what
do you like about Andrew Tate I just
don't like a lot of his viewpoints I
think they're just misogynistic can you
give me an example of something he said
about women that you don't like
um
I really don't know anything off the top
of my head I really just hear like
things online
um you can't be one example you don't
like this guy you think you should be in
jail you have to be able to give me one
example
okay well here's one thing he said that
that a man should look after a woman
like a man should pay for a woman a man
should protect her what do you think
about that I agree with that one so it
sounds like you do like him I'm giving
you a couple of examples and it sounds
like you do like him I like those few
points gotcha [__] do you think you
should be in jail just because you know
like you don't like his take on women no
I don't okay I don't think he should be
a joke because he doesn't like women I
think that he should be in jail because
whatever he did he was obviously there
for a purpose and I did he get out
earlier than you're supposed to so they
held him without a trial at all so he
had no fair trial and they had no
evidence they just held him while they
tried to build a case and they couldn't
find any evidence so they let him go
they've been doing this for a year now
okay
in that case then maybe he shouldn't be
in jail I still don't like Andrew Tate
though but maybe he shouldn't be okay so
we've done a whole 360. yeah we've done
it 360.
I don't agree with everything he says
but I do agree with what he says about
like it's supposed to be the husband's
job to like provide for a family and
that like it's the husband's job to like
take like be the protector of the family
and be strong and be masculine and work
and be successful I agree with all that
stuff that he says um I feel like that's
oh he's saying because the truth is like
when something bad happens say you're
with your husband you're in bed and
there's a there's a robbery and somebody
comes in with a gun who do you expect to
go downstairs and attack this this
rubber right exactly and like a man
that's not strong a man that like let's
say doesn't have a gun he's not strong
he you know he's weak is he gonna be
able to do that no right so we need a
strong man to protect the ladies
completely agree nothing misogynistic
about that no we'll be like Audrey day
so I think we couldn't agree on
everything there were some things we
agreed on some things we just couldn't
agree on but I definitely think I was
able to talk a little bit of sense into
them but you know what I did notice
everybody here was extremely civilized
compared to my London video where I
really thought a feminist was going to
hit me anyway guys that's all from this
video If you enjoyed this kind of
content then please don't forget to hit
the like button and subscribe with the
notifications Bell on because we have so
much more juicy content just like this
coming very soon